[Music]
what are the best ways to make money on
youtube this year and what are the
alternative ways other than youtube
adsense to ultimately go part-time or
even full-time on youtube in this
special episode of the grow with video
live show i'm welcoming two powerful
guests that are gonna be sharing
multiple different ways seven in fact of
how they've been able to not just serve
people make a difference in people's
lives entertain and educate but also
build their income
with youtube and online video so all
that and more is coming up on the grow
with video live show today
[Music]
what is up sean cannell here and i'm so
fired up for today's episode of the grow
with video live show i've got with me
christina patterson and sean chandler
and we're going to be diving into the
content in just a second but can you
smash the like button and let me know
where are you joining us from maybe
you're here on the replay maybe you are
here live we're actually multi-streaming
this our 1k challenge is a part of this
today and we're over on youtube and
we're in some different facebook groups
so shout me out and the think media team
is hanging out live
with you today but i'm excited to dive
into this content we've got seven
powerful tips for you but i want to
welcome our first guest christina
patterson to the show
she is the creator of beloved women and
uh it's a youtube channel with 33 000
subscribers i'm gonna let her tell us a
little bit about her story and when she
started youtube and how she got to where
she is today christina welcome tell us a
little bit about yourself thank you so
much sean first i just want to thank you
for allowing me to be here to chat with
you today i'm just so inspired uh by
what you and the think media team are
doing so it's such an honor to just be
here i'm excited um and again you
inspired me with youtube
and i started off as a
stay-at-home mom i'm actually a
stay-at-home mom and
um
i was
having just a desire and a heart this is
one of my first videos
and um i had a heart to share what god
was teaching me during my quiet time and
so i started blogging then i started
podcasting and then i started thinking
about doing videos and at this time
there weren't really there there weren't
much christian content on youtube at the
time like there is now and so i wasn't
really sure about it but i was like you
know what let's go ahead and start
posting some videos and since then i've
grown an amazing community of sisters
that have the same passion as me for
god's word and um to study his word
together and we have grown from zero
subscribers to uh 300 uh the 33 000 and
we actually last week we actually hit 1
million views and that was just like
crazy to me and so
as someone with a heart that wanted to
inspire others
i always thought that i needed to like
speak on a stage and like be flying all
over the world to do that and so i was a
little discouraged early on because i
wasn't getting speaking engagements i
didn't know really how to go about doing
that
i wasn't like traditionally published i
didn't have like these big connections
to have like this you know new york
times bestseller book to get my
inspirational messages out and so over
the years i've seen how
youtube has been an amazing tool to
reach
thousands upon thousands of women and um
so i'm so excited to be here to share
more about my story
and how we've been able to not only use
youtube to
share our message but also to generate
revenue so that we can continue to share
that message yeah i love that and and
your story is so inspiring and one of
the things we talk about is we need
money for the mission and i think that a
lot of people can relate to you because
uh mainly they're they're impact driven
first they want to make an impact make a
difference but of course in today's
episode we're also talking about well
how do you make a living at the same
time so you can even reach further um
with your message so i'm excited to get
into those strategies in just a second
but we also have another guest with us
today
and this is sean chandler talks about
and sean chandler uh is an incredible
individual he's actually uh one of our
video ranking academy students that i
ran into a couple years ago before the
pandamic at an event in san diego and um
i'm excited for you to be thanks for
coming on the show to share some of your
tips but let us know a little bit about
your story sean
yeah so uh
my youtube channel is all about talking
about movies way too much but i actually
put up my very first movie webpage way
back in the late 90s it was a jackie
chan fan web page where you could like
click on each part of his body to find
out in which movie he hurt that part of
his body doing his stunt but i didn't
stick with it had the little counter in
the corner and through me clicking
refresh i got it up to a thousand
clicks or whatever and then i abandoned
it and then i had some vlogs all
throughout the years about all about
movies my passion for movies and then i
abandoned them and then about 10 years
ago i started noticing some other people
talking about movies on youtube and so i
put up my very first little test videos
on youtube the ones that you're putting
up on screen right now i was a youth
pastor at my church at the time and you
can even see in some of those videos uh
me and the children's ministry classroom
shooting a movie review of the movie
that i saw the night before but i didn't
stick with it i was just too busy and
then jump forward to summer 2016 i kind
of crashed and burned in life was in a
reset phase where i'd um kind of was out
of ministry and was unemployed and had
no clue what i was going to do with the
rest of my life and for a random date
night went to go see the ghostbusters
movie with the lady ghostbusters and on
the internet everyone was either like
thought it was the best movie ever or
the worst movie ever and the people that
thought it was the worst movie thought
the people that liked it were idiots and
the people that thought the people that
didn't like it that were like sexist and
i was like it's just a movie what if i
tried to share like a normal opinion
about it and so i posted this video
basically on a whim
and i stuck with it and i had a little
bit of success a couple weeks later
and just had the time at that phase of
my life to post videos but it was a very
very slow process of figuring out
what would work for my channel what was
the thing that um where i would stand
out my space and so it's about nine
months in i figured out that if i do a
movie review it gets like 100 views and
if i do a ranking of the franchise it
gets 500 views and i went wait i'm not
great with math but 500 is more than 100
and so i just started reverse
engineering what had been working and
applying some of those principles and
then at about 18 months into the whole
process it just really started to take
off
and i was able to quit my day job and go
full time on youtube in
uh february of 2019 about two and a half
years into my youtube journey
really committing to it man i love your
story and i appreciate you sharing that
and and i want to get to these tips and
you know one of the promises that i made
um
as we were talking about seven different
ways to earn your first or next a
thousand dollars on youtube which is our
topic today is is is without adsense but
i figured we'd start there number one
starting with youtube adsense and i want
to start with christina uh with what
you've learned as it pertains to when
did you get monetized and what have you
personally experienced with youtube
adsense and then we're gonna get into a
lot of different creative ways that are
out of the box um but uh christina yeah
what has been kind of your experience
with youtube ads
yeah youtube adsense was actually
the first money that i made on youtube
and it really meant a lot to me at the
time even though it was just a few cents
i had posted a book review on a
christian book that i liked and i didn't
really even think book reviews would get
that many views but it ended up being at
the time one of my most popular videos
and i remember looking at the reports um
the analytics for that video and it said
i earned two cents and i don't know that
doesn't seem like that's not a lot but
to me it was like a seed like oh this
works and like i shared with you before
you know i'm a stay-at-home mom and so
before i was working it was my husband
and myself we were working and when i
became pregnant with our first daughter
we decided that i would stay home so it
was a leap of faith then to go from two
people with two incomes to three people
with one income and so for me to just
see like oh i can make money from home
and uh generate income it really meant a
lot to me and so that two cents was just
a seed and i was like i'm just gonna
keep doing this i'm just gonna keep
posting videos and so we've been able to
grow our adsense as well and then add
other income uh streams also
i love it and i'm curious sean chandler
what's been your experience and and
percentage lee how is um what percentage
of revenue is youtube ad revenue for
like your youtube business basically
sean
for me it's a pretty high percentage
because in the movie space it's such a
popular
category that it's pretty easy to get
views and so in which case it kind of
drives revenue and then likewise the
seasons where they put out big movies
like christmas
that's what ad rates are crazy so when
like spider-man no way home came out in
december
i it was just bananas kind of what was
rolling in and so adsense is is a pretty
decent chunk for me because it's just
easy to get money in that in that
category
but it wasn't so much in 2020
when the universe decided not to put out
movies for that makes sense a year and
so that's where a bunch of the stuff
that we're going to talk about in here
having those other strategies was
extremely important to like flesh out
the
business as a whole and have a holistic
strategy and not just kind of rely on
the easy thing because
people go to the movies all the time and
they want to watch videos about it very
frequently
but strong
yeah well let's let's dive into the next
one too because you know even here we've
covered adsense at length and on our
think media channel but i want to get
into talking about affiliates and
christina let's talk about this with you
uh we talked a little bit about
affiliates we've talked uh today in our
challenge and we've talked about it
other place the summary being you know
you share a product you personally love
and use if you talk about a book you
love you can share an amazon link if
someone clicks on it and purchase it
purchases it you get a commission but
there's also other affiliate pro
products so what has been your
experience with this one christina
um i am an amazon affiliate and so when
i do do book reviews or even when i
share my own books i always use my
affiliate link and so we've been able to
generate income that way and it's super
easy because i don't always have to be
the one to create the product if there's
some there's a book that i like that i
want to share that i know our viewers
are going to like and they're going to
want to read it then i share that
affiliate link in the description of the
video or if i'm interviewing someone and
they've written a book or created some
sort of product on amazon i've been able
to share that affiliate link in the
description as well so
it is a very simple way to get started
with generating income without having to
produce your own product or create your
own product or invest money in your own
product
and when did you first sign up for
amazon associates
it was i think it was
20
17 18.
remember maybe how big your channel was
because people wonder there's not an
exact number we can't say an exact
number but a lot of times you want to
sign up once you already have a little
bit of momentum things have changed over
the years they have but did were you a
ways into your channel
no i was definitely
probably under a thousand subscribers at
that point yeah for sure we we recommend
a lot of times we recommend if you get
if you're getting 50 100 200 views of
video um you have a little bit of
momentum sign up because the other thing
is you need to make a certain number of
qualified sales with i believe in 45
days that might have been different back
when you signed up i know that was a
little bit different uh for me as well
but uh and that's a question we've been
getting um sean i'm curious because uh
what different i don't want to get into
the
the next point but what you you
mentioned some niche affiliate sites so
a lot of people have heard about amazon
uh what are uh what's you have a story
of a niche affiliate site that made you
like five hundred dollars or something
like yes yeah tell me that
i have a movie channel and there's this
program called moviepass which uh
basically it was a subscription service
where you could go see a movie every
single day of the month for a set cost
and so i was just a member of that uh as
because i was reviewing movies so it's
just cheaper to have this service and i
looked and they had an affiliate program
and if you got someone to sign up you'd
get twenty dollars per person that
signed up and so this was
six months into my channel i signed up
for this and started making
twenty forty dollars per month but it
was a little bit more of a it was
designed for movie lovers initially
then
in august of 2017 they changed their
business model to make it a service for
everyone and so they dropped the cost
per month from fifty dollars per month
down to ten dollars per month so for the
cost of one movie ticket you could go
see a movie every single day
and i was a part of the affiliate
program and every person that you signed
up for this you would get ten dollars
well when you have a movie channel
that's an irresistible offer for every
single person that would subscribe or
watch my channel because ten dollars per
month for unlimited movies and so in the
first 12 months of my channel from
adsense i made
466
13th month i made 500
just from this one niche affiliate
program now granted this was not a good
business model for them and so this only
lasted for about nine months that they
could have this program running but
basically i just found something that
was a great deal for my target audience
something that anyone that likes my type
of content would be interested in this
service
and then i made a video called
moviepass explained that just explained
how moviepass worked and so all the
people searching like is this a scam
like that this sounds too good to be
true they searched and they found my
videos and i all along the way that i've
been using it i did monthly little
reviews
of my experience of like i went to see
this many movies and so i saved this
much money it would have cost this much
instead it was only this much here's my
experience here's the hiccups i ran into
so as soon as they dropped their price
and it became a mainstream product for
everyone
my number two of my top 10 videos for
that month movie pass related number one
video for that month movie pass related
and all of them driving to that
affiliate link and so even though my
channel wasn't all that big at the time
500
from signing people up for moviepass
that's amazing and that that bomb drop
right there deserves a like button smash
for sure um and i think what's
encouraging about that is um yes there's
amazon and and and yes there's uh you
know dick's sporting goods and target
and walmart and different affiliate
programs you can do but moviepass
it's out of the box you you just gotta
find that creative idea and where the
world is going with e-commerce and
online services and subscription
services and software and you know today
we're seeing sean chandler working with
like nordvpn and different things like
that you can also be an affiliate even
if it's not a sponsor and so there's so
many different things
who's your audience and how could you
connect something that would serve them
be relevant for them even into your
content even if it's not direct what
does nordvpn have to do ultimately with
movies but if they want to protect their
privacy or if they want to get into an
ip service so they can watch netflix as
if they're in you know the uk then
you're bridging that gap and so really
really creative idea there where we're
gonna keep it going with sean because
this third idea though this blew my mind
and i think this was back in san diego
when i ran into sean and he was saying
man not only am i one of the video
ranking academy students but i'm full
time now i'm like he's like i got an
entertainment channel i'm like well
how'd you do it what was one of the ways
that you are generating income and he
told me this story about audible
affiliates sean break this down and what
exactly happened here
so the audible affiliate program
basically
anyone that you get to sign up for a
free trial of audible you get a 15
bonus for doing that and anyone that
signs up for a free trial audible gets a
free audible audiobook which is once
again an irresistible deal they pay
nothing and they get something for free
and then for me i get 15
and as for my audience it's based off my
demographics it's like 15 to 25 year
olds and 90
dudes and that's not a category of
people that typically
are known for reading books or listening
to audiobooks but the deal itself is
just an irresistible deal
so the it chapter 2 came out in 2019
this big gigantic movie based off of
stephen king book and so then in my
coverage of
the it movie my movie review my ranking
of the different movies i just said hey
this is based off of stephen king book
if you want to check out the very long
stephen king book for free go to
audibletrial.com
sean chandler and you can download the
audiobook for free by signing up for a
free trial just put that in there and
the video did solid numbers did solid
for adsense
but it did 10 times as much
for
audible affiliates
and so it was like okay well that's
that's a good lesson learned right there
that's a good little strategy you think
how many movies come out that are based
off books a ton of them and whatever
niche you're in whatever you cover there
are books about that subject you do
how-to stuff there are books that expand
upon whatever you're covering there's
research videos that i do about the
history of movies
and i whatever book i use whatever my
sources are hey if you would like to get
this book for free check out the link
down below audibletry.com sean chandler
and so that one was a big gigantic one
for me of realizing that's a strategy
just to make 10 times as much for
certain videos then the other thing that
happened back to 2020 where i just think
smarter about my strategy and not just
kind of rely on the easy adsense side to
things for where i was at
was i started thinking tangentially like
okay
movies aren't coming out but books still
are coming out and i think star wars
you can look behind me big star wars fan
covers star wars all the time on my
channel star wars books were coming out
during the pandemic
so i put out a review of one of the new
star wars books and put an audible
affiliate in there for this new line of
books that they were doing once again
video did decent decent adsense
10 times as much from audible affiliates
and then the one that was just crazy
from this last month the batman came out
was the biggest movie of last month and
my review for it did crazy good
but they came out with a prequel book
called before the batman
and so i reviewed the book
posted video with the affiliate link
like hey if you want to check it out
link's down below
you can get it for free
and this video that actually got like
one-tenth the number of views because it
was more niche sort of thing
made just as much money as my big
gigantic hit review of the batman and so
even something that like does
significantly less numbers
can make just as much money because it
had a better monetization strategy built
into it
man you're dropping bombs and and what's
so cool about this is just thinking so
creatively thinking outside of the box
and again yeah some of your videos is
this the video right here that we're
looking at
uh so that that's a different um that's
one on canceled movies where that's one
where i used uh cited all my sources and
so it was actually an amazon affiliate
one i did for that one but right before
that you can see
in the right below where you're at
you'll see kind of my my uh every bat
suit ranked every batman villain right
it'll be uh coupled before that like a
week or two before that okay march was
the month of batman ones
yeah a lot of batman almost said bottom
right bottom right that's a whole
strategy batman forever or uh before the
batman right there before the batman
book review okay so also that's that's a
whole strategy right there of thinking
about themes thinking about what's
happening when's it happening you go all
in on batman but look at this so
creative you grab this prequel novel
14 000 views as you said which again is
not like adsense wise that's not gonna
be significant
but you're saying that what was the the
way you earned money specifically from
this was an affiliate for that i was an
audible affiliate linking people hey if
you're interested in the book audible
you can listen to it for free gotcha
boom and so you can see that right here
you can just grab this and you're
getting
per sign up for the audible affiliate
uh you get a commission of 15 or
something
15 per person that signs up to get a
free book to get a free book free book
which is that's a great deal for that
a lot of us could use just because we
you know you kind of tie it in who
doesn't want to listen to you know like
christina you might want to listen to
something about your faith tie it into
batman something about business
something about health something about a
celebrity so many different things on
audible man another like smash for uh
sean drop it what do you got and it's
not disruptive i think that's the thing
that's best about it you're offering
something that to the person that wants
it is like
why wouldn't i want a free book like i
was interested in the book and you told
me how i can get it for free it's an
extra layer of value when you find a
great affiliate program that offers
something for free offers a great
discount and you plug it in
it doesn't people aren't annoyed by it
they don't feel like they need to skip
it they appreciate that you're thinking
about how can you serve them on one
extra level
yes so amazing well uh man you're
watching the growth video live show we
just dropped tip number three of seven
ways to make money we actually have a
bonus tip so you're gonna want to stick
around to the end we're talking about
adsense we're talking about affiliates
we're talking about audible affiliates
but number four is physical products or
merch and christina has some serious
wisdom to drop on this one and so
christina break it down
you're an author you've created some
journals explain how you've been able to
monetize with physical products and
merch
yes you know uh my most popular video to
date is
my video where i teach my 4r bible study
method it's a the simple topic is how to
study the bible
and so i go through read reflect respond
request that's my four r's and so as i
was writing the script for that video i
was like you know it would be really
nice if people had like a journal and
they could write you know answer the
questions for each um whatever scripture
they're reading with the for our bible
study method and so i was like okay well
let me create a journal first um before
i post this video not even knowing that
it was going to be one of my most
popular videos and created this life
bible journal at first it was just one
design
we've expanded since then and then been
able to create other products around it
so there are scripture cards where it
has the 4r bible study questions on the
back of the card that align with the
method that we study the bible with
and so it's been really good because we
have a way where we can encourage
our viewers to study the bible for
themselves we're teaching you how to
study the bible how to meditate on the
bible spiritual disciplines and things
like that but our products are in
alignment with how we're serving our
audience and so it's really a win-win
for us to generate income so that we can
continue our impact and our mission but
also it's a great way to serve our
audience to get them excited to actually
do the things that we're teaching them
to do
that is so inspiring but i want to
take it back to the beginning here
because as we look at this now
this is amazing you've got multiple
designs there's a whole page of products
the website is incredible but i know our
community is like well how do i build a
website and how do i like get that take
me down to like 1.0 you mentioned there
was only one design to start how did you
figure out originally how to design it
get it printed and get it online and
what were the tools that you used or
hosting website and things like that
right i did a lot of research to find
different publishers because i really
wanted it to be spiral bound it didn't
have to be i'm actually seeing a lot of
people doing
journals and planners on amazon and just
self-publishing there and being really
successful there um so but i found a
publisher that could do spiral and i
ordered
25. i ordered 25 journals and i was like
okay let me see if i can sell these and
how long it's going to take and so we
sold them within a month and so then i
ordered 50 journals
and then we sold those in like a month
or two and so then i was like okay i
think that we can really do this and so
then i ordered you know 100 journals and
so we just kind of just we started small
because i didn't necessarily know that
it was
going to be successful financially if it
was going to be profitable um and so i
didn't have anything to lose because i
just started small with what we had
and then we just grew from there every
each year
that's really encouraging it's not about
your resources it's about your
resourcefulness and building up one
thing at a time it's starting with the
25 journals not the 25 000 journals
right and having them in your garage and
like what am i going to do with these
um what did you build this website out
yourself what do you use i did so this
is shopify okay and shopify and this is
the first website i use to
um sell the life bible journal on and
it's pretty user friendly um just
drag and drop and pretty much if you
know how to do wordpress or if you know
how to upload a youtube video
you can use shopify as well
and then are you a graphic designer
yourself and that's and you come up with
the designs yourself
um originally i did but i use creative
market to find designs uh my the first
design was ordered off creative market
and i kind of just redesigned some stuff
myself i'm self-taught on photoshop just
from google searching and then um these
recent designs i actually hired a
designer off
99designs.com
to create the images for me i kind of
told her what i wanted and she created
all of the flowers and the arrangements
and the
the theme that i was going for and so
then i was able to just use what she
created because i don't know how to
create those designs from scratch and
just put the covers together how i
thought i wanted them to be man that's
amazing and and you're you're like the
conductor of the orchestra you're you're
you're you have a vision you're turning
your vision into reality i've got a
vision of these journals start with what
you have but going from creative market
to 99 designs getting your skills in
photoshop as well but in some cases
you're you're outsourcing you're getting
right someone to help with the spiral
using shopify and and i want to
encourage our community too because you
know as you're leaning into this this
can be can feel very overwhelming but
that's why we're all about skill
building that's why start small that's
why i take one step at a time and you
can do this like you can learn each
thing get your first 25 journals right
get signed up for amazon audible
affiliates or whatever it is and then
once you have momentum i've learned this
you can't steer
a parked car
you got to just start moving and once
you start moving you start getting more
answers you start scaling up you have a
little bit of money to reinvest and so
that is super super powerful um and so
cool to see christina and so those are
those the uh those are all the physical
products right journals as well as cards
did you start with the cards
uh we start well actually the first
physical product would be books and so i
was self-publishing on amazon they have
a program called kdp where you can
self-publish and um they essentially do
everything for you you upload the book
and they
it's like print on demand but for books
so someone orders off amazon and they
give you a
royalty for that book
and so i started with just
self-publishing a book and then doing
some bible studies promoting them on my
youtube channel and so one of my books
that i did was called relentless joy
it was a bible study through the book of
philippians and so what i did was i
created corresponding
videos for each chapter in the book and
so i told my audience hey we got this
bible study video bible study series
coming out get the book the video series
is free go ahead and get the book on
amazon
and
again you know this is just me starting
and not really knowing how things will
work out and it was a huge success that
book was a um number one amazon
bestseller in like two of its categories
and i did not even expect that um
because it was just like people were
like oh i want to go through this series
and i want this book that's going to
help me follow along and so that is one
of the main ways every time i come out
with a bible study series there is a
workbook to go along with it and it's
self-published through amazon
i don't have to pay anyone to publish
the book for me um amazon they take i
think it used to be
uh they would give you 70 but i think
they've
uh only they're doing 60 now with the
amazon royalties but i mean
it's still
a lot
for me when you are um when you have an
audience that that likes your content
and they're like oh okay i can get a 13
book
man that's amazing and i want to talk a
little bit more about uh that as well
and we have actually four more
strategies coming up in just a second uh
but this is the growth video live show
and i want to remind you we're just a
few weeks away from grow with video live
check out this video this thing is your
gateway to get out of the thing that you
complain about but people would rather
complain about how it is than put in the
work we need to start understanding how
big this opportunity is because for
everybody in this room you will sit back
in 20 30 years and regret if you didn't
execute in this era it has never been a
better time in the human race ever to
actually just go all in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
[Music]
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
welcome back to the grow with video live
show we're gonna get um into some more
tips on how to earn your first or next a
thousand dollars from our special guest
but i want to remind you a couple things
first of all growth video lives a couple
weeks away alex from ozy patrickbetdavid
gary vaynerchuk heather taurus vanessa
lau jasmine star so many speakers and
you can see all the details at
growethvideolive.com
but today's a special episode of the
grow with video live show because we're
in the middle of our tube 1k challenge
even though you might be seeing this on
a facebook page or on youtube we
actually have a very limited offer going
on right now that doesn't just include a
ticket to grow a video live but it also
includes our signature program called
video ranking academy so if you're
serious about growing on youtube this
year and expanding video onto multiple
platforms and you want to really go deep
and build this into a side income or a
part-time or full-time income check out
learnvideo2022.com there's three
different levels because you can attend
this conference virtually you can attend
it in person at a general admission
level or there's also a vip level that
includes lunches and a couple extra
perks and so this is a limited offer if
you hear my voice right now if you are
watching this video if you're watching
this on the replay there's probably not
much time left so
learnvideo2022.com is where the details
are for that and i hope you don't miss
this year it's a once in a lifetime
lineup i've never seen
patrick david from valuetainment at any
event let alone with gary vaynerchuk
with some of the other speakers that we
have evan carmichael's coming out uh pat
flynn chalene johnson it's gonna be
incredible so learnvideo22.com
or check out the post the youtube
description the comments find that link
and check out the details because it's
ending very soon listen we're talking
all about seven different ways to earn a
thousand dollars on youtube and uh to
ultimately start building up your income
whether that's adsense once you get
monetized we've covered affiliates
through amazon or even through things
like moviepass and niche accounts we've
covered
audible affiliates which is so cool and
sean chandler's been schooling us on
that and then christina was talking
about physical products or merch talking
all about making her own journals or her
own scripture cards but we have a couple
more to go through here and we have a
bonus tip so stick around and smash the
like button if you've been getting value
today number five is monthly
memberships and so one of the things
that when i was asking christina ahead
of time
about you know what are some ways to to
earn money you mentioned christina give
exclusive content to your super fans by
offering a membership uh tell me a
little bit about this
yeah you know
um you're our you're providing content
on youtube um and there are going to be
people that just absolutely love
everything that you're putting out and
there are people that will want even
more and so if you can somehow provide
more exclusive content maybe it's an
extra video a week or maybe it's a
full-length video and you're only
putting maybe certain segments on
youtube you could potentially create a
membership where people pay you each
month so that they can get that extra
content i know you've probably seen
people with patreons um or even youtube
offers its own membership within your
youtube channel that you could offer to
people and charge membership levels
depending on how much you give your
audience
with memberships it could be digital um
content like extra videos but it could
also be like templates it could whatever
you're offering them it could also be a
physical product that maybe you mail out
each month and so you can get really
creative with it but just think of
additional content that your super fans
would absolutely love and wouldn't mind
paying an additional fee for each month
and it's been really helpful for us
because it's more consistent revenue
that's coming in every single month
and so what do you use to join your
membership
okay so i'm actually using
vimeo ott because
there's an app uh portion to it so
there's the membership but then you have
app access so we have the beloved women
app which i love because we wanted there
to be
a community aspect to our membership
where we can send you notifications we
can do lives within the app
and i have
we can do
pdf downloads extras that we give our
app members our app membership members
um and so that is what our membership
looks like and we're using vimeo ott
right now as the platform to run our
membership on
that's amazing and so uh we will um you
can check out belovedwomen.org and you
can see details really cool and and did
you launch on that platform too was it
been user friendly
is that where it all started
that is where it all started so i just
launched on the web first for free and
then
again my whole story as you can tell is
we got to start small and then we just
take little baby steps and we grow from
there so we didn't originally have the
apps but i did launch using the vimeo
ott platform
and that was actually free um to
actually create an account and upload
videos and i picked them because i it
was a good video platform and the
primary content
the exclusive content that we would be
providing our members would be video so
that's why i chose them but if you're
going to be doing training maybe you
might do kajabi or teachable or
something like that so you would pick a
platform that best works for your
audience and the type of content that
you're going to be providing but we
picked them we started off with just
their web
um
level and then i had a goal i was like
when we get to this number of members
then we will up our you know our
platform
and we will do the apps and offer apps
to our members and things like that so
we started small and we just grew from
there
start small and grow from there but i'm
excited because sean chandler talks
about also is doing memberships um but
you're using patreon so sean
talk about when this started and uh
what's been your experience
so i started on patreon uh about a year
into my channel right around when i had
about a thousand subscribers and i
started doing some
larger scale projects and videos and was
just looking for an additional way to
monetize things
and so early on i had
about you know
basically in the beginning section of my
uh patreon or journey by the point in
time that i hit a thousand dollars from
adsense i'd made 625 dollars from
patreon and about 15 patrons and so
early on it was a big percentage of what
was kind of working for me and
essentially it was
letting people have more say into what i
was going to cover and offering
additional videos that's kind of what i
did at the beginning of things and more
recently as i've kind of been able to
fine-tune things and my audience has
grown
the
two things i do the one thought is
basically people on patreon get more
access to me so i just do a weekly q a
and when you have a channel my size if i
do a q a on my main channel there's
hundreds and hundreds of people that are
trying to ask me questions and so if i
do one on patreon i can answer
everybody's questions and so it's a
really good hook to get people to join
anytime i do a live stream on my main
channel like hey join at any level over
on patreon we do a weekly q a and i can
answer all your questions
and then the other thing that i do is on
my channel i do a lot of like top 10
lists
and top 10 best action movies top 10
best comic book movies and so every time
i do one of those videos i do a second
video on patreon with five more
and so it's basically the same way that
streaming services try and hook you that
they'll put two episodes out for free
that anybody can watch whenever they
first open up the service you get the
seven day free trial when you can watch
the first two episodes or whatever you
get hooked on the show
and then you have to sign up to see the
rest of it and so i kind of do that with
my top tens where people like i wonder
where he put this one i wonder if this
one in there so every time i do one of
those it just hooks people pulls a new
group of people in
but it's just looking how can i add
extra value extra expertise in a
sustainable way and so for me doing a
weekly live stream that's actually a lot
of fun because it's not overwhelming the
way it is on my main channel it's fun to
just get to talk with people
and they get much more access to me and
have that back and forth in a way that
in the comments section it's not as easy
to do that
um and so then likewise kind of a perk
in there too of you can have like a zoom
call with me every month at the top tier
so just do you have a question you want
to ask me about movies and just sit down
and talk about movies with me
i've got a group of people i talk with
them every month it's pretty cool to get
to do that and patreon
jumped back to 2020 when
kind of the whole movie stopped coming
out
adsense ad rates all dramatically drop
i was totally fine patreon just filled
right in on the gap of the inconsistency
of
adsense was it a problem patreon just
filled in that gap because i just
offered more value to the super fans and
they were able to make everything
perfectly fine during a very tumultuous
year especially in a specific space
where the thing that fuels a movie
channel is new movies no new movies in
2020
and i didn't i didn't have to sweat it
at all because of patreon
man that's great and that's a power tip
right there too
you know what you're learning from both
christina and from sean is as
diversifying your income because you
know there might 2020 might happen ad
revenue might go down but you got
journals or you got patreon or you've
written a book um or you have you know
these other income streams i saw a
question come in um asking about the
site christina was uni using it's called
vimeo ott
over the top and uh i believe christina
wright it allows you to kind of do your
own branded app because this becomes
your own app and you can see these these
branded apps are using vimeo as the
technology
for um starting out with like a dollar a
subscriber or starting out at 500 a
month and there's these different levels
um and so this would just be one way to
create the experience that christina
wanted to create um sean you know uses
patreon which i believe they take five
percent of your revenue and but you can
upload videos right there and then it's
a member's access area uh for there um
as well and so uh really really powerful
tips um and we still got more to get
into we're gonna be laying in the plane
but we got three more so we're gonna
keep it moving um the next one you could
do is you could create a course and so
this is an opportunity to package what
you know create a course christina
you've done this uh talk a little bit
about what you did with creating a
course
uh yes i actually
was
very hesitant about creating the course
i was pushing it away for a really long
time because
i do get people that ask me well how do
you do what you do essentially a course
is where you're going to teach people
how you do what you do and my friend one
of my close friends like christina you
need to create a course and i was just
like no i got to do my bible study
videos i got to stay focused on the
mission you know um and so finally this
year i was like you know what i've
gotten enough questions uh people asking
me okay how do i you're doing this
christian youtube thing how do i start a
christian youtube channel and so i
started a
course to just teach christian women how
to get started on youtube how to share
their god-given message um online with
video and i can tell you that in
one we we've haven't that was the most
money we've made in the shortest amount
of time if that makes sense
and so that was
essential and just so crucial to us
moving forward as a ministry because it
provided money for us to continue to do
those bible study videos so i kind of
had to have like a mind shift about it
and realize that
creating and teaching people how to do
what i do would also fuel me to do what
i actually do and what i actually have a
passion to do which is to teach women
the bible and how to study the bible for
themselves um but also teaching them how
to create their own their own online
ministry
has been significant for us
and i think that's powerful i think what
that speaks to is the seasons too like
right like as we're as we're breaking
this down you might you don't want to
she did that after right you did that
after you had some momentum after you've
done the journal after you did the thing
and then you started to teach the thing
it kind of reminds me of my story before
creating video ranking academy i was
talking about cameras and teaching about
cameras and doing affiliate marketing
and learning how to rank videos and
built the success there and and actually
tested it and figured it out and
stumbled and failed and then i was like
ready to package that in a course and so
all of our paths might be unique in
these different monetization
posts if you will maybe you start some
of them earlier maybe you do them later
so it's kind of nice to know that
there's multiple ways to continue to
evolve your career
in the creator economy would you agree
christina yeah i would totally agree and
i mean creating the course was actually
so fun i already have like two ideas for
my next two courses
and so i actually enjoy it and and i
love the opportunities that it's
presenting for me to do even more of
what i love to do and also
that it's increasing our impact because
now they're going to be other women that
are going to be empowered with not only
just the encouragement but the actual
tools and knowledge to share god's truth
online just like i'm doing so i'm
looking at it also as just like
multiplying what i'm already doing
without having to do more myself
man absolutely incredible inspiring
stuff what's been your aha moment so far
uh think community drop that in the
comments because and which one do you
like best because we got a couple more
here to do but do you like for your
niche adsense best affiliates to start
with audible affiliates physical
products which one of these is right
right for you you don't have to do all
of them these are again like tools in
your toolbar you could pick the
different tools maybe creating a course
or now i'm excited to get into
number seven and christina touched on it
but i just kind of want to circle back
and that is
write a
book and christina has packaged some of
her books i want to make sure i can look
these up on amazon and the best way to
find them this is different than your
journals these are actually books you've
written through amazon
kdp would this be the best way to find
it here or is this is directly from you
yeah this is from me you can go to
amazon and just
probably search relentless joy or
christina patterson
and it should show up but creating
a book was actually my first physical
product that i actually created and i
wrote the book and and i was telling you
again at the beginning about my story
about feeling like oh i needed to be the
speaker traveling the world
found youtube i also felt like oh i
needed this traditional publisher to be
able to write a book
and so i actually pitched my book to
three publishers and it was rejected and
then i just decided i found out about
amazon kdp and i wrote my first book
daughters of fire
and i uh published it on amazon
self-published and i actually absolutely
love the process i love the idea that my
book could actually
be
on the same platform as other authors
that do have traditionally published
books um
and you know amazon is a trusted website
that many people go to every day already
to buy books and so yeah i sell them on
my website as well but i like to think
of
of amazon as kind of like a mall people
are already going there to spend money
so it was a good opportunity for a small
creator to create a product that could
sell well and they did i shared earlier
about how i package all of my video
bible studies
with a workbook to go with them and so
we sell those as well on amazon and so
i've i've i'm like
so passionate about self-publishing and
i don't even really think that much
about traditionally publishing maybe one
day i will
but for right now i'm completely
satisfied with self-publishing and
this was again we were talking a little
bit about how 2020 affected everyone and
my with the life bible journals you know
with the 2020 and everything shutting
down that affected a lot of like
shipping and shipping suppliers and
getting things to people on time
amazon was not late though for the most
part they were shipping those books like
clockwork and so having my books on
amazon was also a benefit for me during
that time because we could still sell
books i was getting i'm you know i was
getting
royalties from those books every single
month regardless if i'm publishing a
book every single month or not so it was
just consistent revenue i put in all of
my videos
by the description of my videos i simply
put um
books by christina and so when people
see my videos and they like a book that
i you know they like the content that
i'm putting out and i've gained trust
with them by providing good quality
content on youtube then it's easy for
them to just go to amazon a trusted
website that they've probably already
purchased from before they if they're an
amazon prime member they're going to get
free shipping it's easy it's an easy
sell you know usually with some other
content like the membership or like the
course i might have to
warm my audience up a little bit more to
make the sale but i've experienced for
myself with a book people are more prone
to just buy it just from watching one or
two videos from me so
it is definitely one of the ways that i
will continue to generate um
income for
our youtube channel and for our business
because one i enjoy writing books um and
two it
works yeah i love that and i saw a
question coming in about um using amazon
kdp and how hard is it what how did you
write the book get it you know edited
and get a cover designed and can anybody
do this can they just because you don't
have to have a books in your um garage
they're either digital or they're print
on demand right so right ultimately they
can come directly from amazon what's it
like using uh kdp and createspace yeah
you know what it's changed over the
years for the most part like my first
book i designed that cover then that all
that fire and going on i want to
redesign that one later one day
um but
i uh the insides of the book the actual
pages i just
i that was like a word document and
in kdp
they will tell you you know
what the dimensions and the margins need
to be they have pretty good
documentation there so i just read the
rules for the requirements and i just
followed them for how to shape uh and
size the pages in word i just used word
and then uploaded it as a pdf and they
cover as a pdf and then of course there
they review it
if there's anything wrong they let you
know but for the most part i felt like
it was pretty simple to use
and actually for all these covers like
that cover right there i designed that
in canva
man amazing i mean that just is it's
inspiring it's like you're just getting
up and doing it you're like i'm just not
under the cover
microsoft word i'm gonna look at the the
settings i was do you know just follow
the instruction i'm gonna you know sit
down write the book upload it online
and and they're probably
can if i'm going to go out on a limb
here they're probably not
perfect is there any like little details
about these books maybe something you
wish was different in the cover or maybe
like is it possible there's one spelling
error in there or punctuation error
yes there is
they are not perfect and you know what
shawn spelling and grammar is like
not my strong suit um i actually do have
an editor that reads all of my content
and edits things for me um but like i
was telling you with the um first book
that i wrote daughters of fire i'm like
i don't love that cover anymore at the
time i thought it was like oh that is
fire and now i'm like oh my gosh you
know um but i always go back to my
purpose in my mission um
with one of my other books the
formatting or how i structured it i'm
like oh now i look back i would have did
it differently you know
but
i got it out
it's done and
i'm more concerned with those small
details than my readers are there their
feedback is wow this book really changed
my life this helped me while i was in
the hospital and that's our mission is
to impact and help women and so as long
as we're doing that i can look over all
those small minor details
yeah i love that dunn is better than
perfect of course you want to honor the
product you're selling and you want to
get it done to a level that
is is delivering value to that end user
but there's always going to be those
perfectionism that can hold us back and
i love it that you just punch fear in
the face you punch perfectionism in the
face and you pressed publish on your
book on uh kdp well we have a bonus tip
we are coming up on the end of our time
but i want to get into the bonus tip i
want to uh
talk about that final eighth strategy of
earning a thousand um dollars on youtube
i want to bring sean back in but i did
see a question too you know i had i
hadn't mentioned i think christina you
joined the video ranking academy in 2017
i think so
that is amazing so was it helpful
specifically uh in in those early days
of you getting started on youtube
oh yes it was helpful because sean
i was staying up late at night to record
my youtube videos while my kids were
asleep so that they them running around
the house wouldn't be in the back of my
videos it was the only quiet time i had
to record my videos and so
i'm putting in all this extra work to
create these videos and they were
getting views but i just felt like there
was more i could be learning about how
to grow on youtube so when i found out
about vra i was like i'm definitely
going to make this investment because i
i wanted to
just fast track that learning curve of
trying to learn how to rank my videos um
and it was such a blessing to me because
what i did after i i'm pretty sure i
like binge watch the entire uh course
and i went back since and watched it a
second time but that i was so excited i
learned how to rank my videos from the
course vra and i went back and i
actually ranked all of my old videos
before i even started publishing new
videos with what i've learned with from
vra and even from the older videos just
updating my thumbnails updating my
descriptions my tags my titles with what
i learned i was starting to see
more growth and more attraction more
views on those videos and so then i was
like okay so we're gonna rank all our
videos moving forward and
that was so
important in our growth of our youtube
channel and our growth of our community
and we've talked again about just kind
of safeguarding yourself financially
when hardships come but even when it
comes to growing on youtube ranking my
videos has helped so much with that in
2020 it was a hard year for everyone
but particularly for me i've had a lot
of health issues over the past two years
and i only posted 12 videos in 2020
that was not my intention i wanted to
post you know two videos a week but i
was only able to post 12 videos and in
that year we went from 20 000
subscribers um to 30 000 subscribers and
so we were still able to grow 10 000
subscribers in that year
um because
we uh had all those videos that were
ranking they were still getting views
they were still working for me even when
i couldn't work for the youtube channel
well i appreciate you saying that and so
grateful you know since then we've we've
re-shot the course a couple times and
we've updated it and and i actually want
to ask uh sean because this is unique
you know uh it video reagan academy
makes a lot more sense for
uh or makes complete linear sense when
you're a channel like christina's or
like think medias when you're very
clearly in kind of education and maybe
teaching something specific but again
you know when you came up to me at that
san diego conference i heard a little
bit about your channel i know we have
all kinds of vloggers and entertainment
channels that have crushed it as vra
students but from your perspective uh
sean
what has it meant to you like how how
was it helpful back when you joined vra
to getting to where you are now
yeah so i joined after i'd had a couple
of videos that were like surprise
successes like oh this is taking off
this might be going somewhere this might
be my new career
i need to figure out how to do this
right i need to learn not just to
stumble into success but how do i repeat
success and that's where i signed up for
video ranking academy to figure out how
to do this and make it sustainable
and a lot of what i got out of that was
just learning to think differently
about how i create videos and think
about ideas so earlier in this video we
talked about how i reviewed before the
batman which is a batman book i'm a
movie channel i don't review books but i
did that because i was thinking about
what is the other
revenue stream how does this
fit with what i'm doing but also expose
me to a new and different audience and
thinking bigger thinking differently
removing the box that i had there about
okay i post videos to get views to get
adsense money and go no no no how do i
design the video
with these other revenue streams in mind
and other things kind of you talked
about in the course about like kit.co a
website where you can make
lists of things that link to like
amazon.com
and it started just thinking through
people ask me all the time what posters
i have in the background hey where can i
get that poster you have and so i used
kit.co that you talked about in video
ranking academy to make a list of all of
my posters
all of my funko pops all the fun stuff
you see in the background behind me
it's just occasionally in my videos
i'll just say hey if you're wondering
where i got these posters hey this cool
shirt that i'm wearing and i link to a
kit.co link and it's answering a
question that people have been asking me
to drive traffic to affiliate mark
affiliate links likewise some things you
kind of talked about how um
when we're talking about batman i said
march was batman month
that was 100 strategic and the way i
designed it was all around how do i feed
one video into the other video into the
other video and so before the movie came
out all of my expectation videos trailer
reactions are like so you know when the
movie comes out i'm going to review all
the older batman movies leading up to it
i'm gonna do a review a spoiler review
and then i'm gonna do a ranking of every
possible thing you can imagine related
to it so i told them in advance what
we're about to do and then when the
movie came out and i started doing these
rankings at some point in time in my
video before i always check my audience
retention so i know where the dip off is
where people stuff that i learned in
video ranking academy study your
audience retention to figure out where
people are actually watching before they
dip off i say hey if you like this video
i've got a bunch of other batman
rankings just like this one i've ranked
up and list off the other videos then i
say i'm about to do
and just all of it is promoting
the other content that we're going to
cover you need to kind of think
if someone is going to sponsor one of my
videos
hundreds thousands of dollars to sponsor
it
that's space in my video that they value
at hundreds to thousands of dollars that
i can use to promote my other content
it's a sort of way of thinking that i
got from video ranking academy just
trying to think it's a holistic big
picture strategy when it comes to
getting people to stay on youtube stay
on my channel and thinking also about uh
how am i going to monetize it from the
ideation from the idea of the video like
when i left watching the batman i
thought oh i need i literally got in my
car pulled out my phone downloaded the
audiobook of before the batman to listen
to it because i knew i wanted to do like
oh that's a perfect example of a video
that would be perfect perfect
to do an uh uh audible affiliate video
for it
and it was started to be very profitable
and that was the thinking very much was
how am i going to monetize this not just
thinking how do i get views how do i get
adsense
i love it
yeah and i mean that's our company is
called think media and i think i i love
how much you said that because it's
really thinking different about your
niche think you're different about
youtube thinking different about the
creator economy and how you're going to
make money thinking different about your
entire approach and thinking more
strategically of course we can't get
into it but we teach the the 7r system
as christina and sean know so well and
the very first r is reverse engineer
it's totally starting with the end in
mind and working backwards and so uh i
appreciate you sharing kind of your
experience
friends i i i feel bad because i've kept
them long past this hour and we need to
touch on this last point and we are
landing the plane but i i definitely
there's been a couple questions you know
you can check out video record academy
anytime you want on seance.com that's
the public price but it's a lot more
expensive it's a big discount we're
running right now at
learnvideo2022 there's a link in the
description where on youtube and then of
course on facebook it should be in this
post um but we have a special bundle
whether that includes our event
um and there's a couple different levels
if you want to come in person or watch
first virtually and one of the things
that um sean and christina they they may
not have even been like have you seen
the new vra master stuff that we just
uploaded yet i don't assume you have not
yet because you guys are already
crushing it but i want to challenge you
because you already are already members
we just uploaded 25 new videos
and video video ranking academy's just
been getting better and we have 75 it
sounds like a lot there's 75 new videos
that we're adding in the next couple
months just because of course we
continue to pioneer and innovate so um
those are there for you and you know one
of the things that is available with bra
right now is the lifetime access at
learn video 2022. so that's where the
details are um i know they got to go
they got families all kinds of stuff but
we have a bonus tip for you and i have
to give it to you we'll go quick the
bonus strategy is
sponsors
and sean touched on this but sean break
it down i spotted one in one of your
videos
nor nordvpn what have you learned about
this and what size did your channel have
to be once you got to this level
so the first sponsorship i got was i
think right around 2000 subscribers
it was only a month after i did a
thousand dollars from adsense so it was
still very early in the process and once
again it was a niche
sponsorship it wasn't kind of generic
product with a big budget it was
an app called stardust that was
basically a social media app for movie
reviews that made it very easy to upload
30-second reactions to movies and they
were looking
to do
looking for influencers to talk about to
drive more people over there and to get
more people on there
and that was the first one i got and it
was a point in time where
even getting just 50 dollars per video
which is what they paid me that was
insane money to me at the time
uh with where my channel was at you know
i would normally get like three dollars
per video and suddenly they want to pay
me 50 per video to talk about an app for
a couple of minutes
and so i got something niche very early
on
but
it takes until
you have to be consistent not just with
your subscribers but with your views
really to be when you start attracting
sponsors where they're interested
because they want to be able to repeat
success they want to be able to know
what they're going to get if they pay
for something so like on my channel when
a sponsor reaches out to me they say hey
we want to put a sponsorship on one of
your ranking videos they don't say i
want to put it on a movie review they
say they want to put on a ranking video
because those ones consistently do get
the higher numbers that are more
consistent in what they get movie
reviews the batman gets crazy numbers
generic netflix movie review does not
get crazy numbers and so then they want
to have a consistency in your viewership
and
typically they'll kind of ask for your
demographics they'll ask for a quote for
how much you want for a sponsorship
uh to to do it for and you kind of
negotiate back and forth on when it is
in the video and how much it'll be
and then they
you find a number in the middle there
that kind of works
and uh the big thing i've kind of
learned is that i need to
not just say yes to everything when the
first time people are like hey we want
to pay you to talk about something for a
minute
like your eyes get better
wow that sounds amazing
it's not always amazing um because it's
you have to believe in the product you
have to be really excited about it and
you also have to think about the fact of
it's extra work to do it you have to
work with people one of the great things
about doing youtube full-time is is i
work for myself and and sponsorships
mean you have to work with someone else
so there can be some complications to it
but i think the big thing if you're
looking to get strategies is to be
plugged into the community of your niche
so that first sponsorship i got
i built the connection to get it by
going to a film festival and at the film
festival they were the sponsorship for
the film festival was the stardust app
and they just wanted people to use it
and so i just used their app while i was
at it and then the guy that was running
it approached me and started talking to
me we exchanged information and a month
later he's offering
to
pay me money to talk about his app
uh on my channel and so it's just kind
of being in the community meeting people
and then now that i've been doing this
for a while i have a enormous number of
movie critic friends and that are
youtubers
and we exchange information about
sponsorships and who's easy to work with
and just even within the last month i
had some uh a streaming service reach
out to me about doing a sponsorship that
i thought
that's a little bit too niche for me i
don't think i could bring the excitement
to it but i've got my friends over there
this is perfect for them and so i just
referred
the streaming service over to my friend
to check to check them out because it's
a better
um partnership between the better
collaboration
uh an overlap of audience and so then
just knowing other people in your niche
that are around the same size as you and
if you see someone's your friend of
yours and they get a sponsorship you can
just ask your friend like do you have
the contact information that seemed like
a good fit for me too
you can start building connections
and then
just if there's things that you like
products that you actually like
that you use that tie into your niche
reach out to them just
on social media wherever you can to see
if they might be interested in
sponsoring something that you're doing
wow so many valuable nuggets and tips in
there eight strategies that we shared
today on how to earn a thousand dollars
plus
on youtube and i just want to thank our
guests so much first christina thank you
so much for being on and um if people
want to check you out uh give a shout
out to your stuff i'll put it on screen
as well but go ahead and give us the
voiceover oh yeah well of course you can
just search belovedwomen on
youtube and you will find our channel
there or go to
belovedwomen.org and that's where you
can find all of our social links
amazing appreciate you so much and thank
you for sharing your valuable wisdom and
tips and advice with us today people got
so much
value and sean how about your channel
where can we connect with you and get
the scoop on the the latest series and
collections of films
if you head to youtube and search for
sean chandler you will either find an
nfl player or a guy that looks like me
and that's talking about movies it's the
guy that looks like me and is talking
about movies and whatever new releases
are coming out we got a harry potter
movie coming out in the next week and i
will be covering it ranking the
franchise all of that fun stuff amazing
well sean thank you so much you dropped
some very unique uh advice today and
christina as well so many valuable tips
and so appreciate you both thanks again
and can we show some love in the
comments as well as smash the like
button for christina and sean's sharing
their time with us uh today and their
advice friends this has been the grow
with video live show we're coming at you
weekly on the countdown to grow with
video live uh i saw some questions
coming in uh specifically about video
ranking academy um details about it is
it sequential it is it actually has a
quick start course so if you're very
busy and then it just unpacks as you
want to go through layers so you can
take it at your own pace um but you can
learn all the details at
learnvideo2022.com there's even a place
to chat or leave a message it will get
back to you in the lower right hand of
the screen so if you want to talk to
somebody on the think media team just go
to
learnvideo2022.com for a very limited
time you actually can take advantage of
not just video ranking academy but also
a ticket to grow with video live that's
happening in person and online may
2022 so if you um want to uh this is the
time to go all in if you're saying i
want to be serious about youtube serious
about online video and i want the best
offer that think media has ever done in
terms of online education through an
online course and our experiential event
with gary vaynerchuk patrick bett david
chalene johnson uh aaron on demand um so
anthony o'neil so many great speakers
that are gonna be there so um learn all
the details at learnvideo2022
and thanks again for being here for the
grow with video live
show
i'll see you soon do you want to get in
the room with experts like gary
vaynerchuk patrick vette david vanessa
lau pat flynn chalene johnson and more
and would you like to meet hundreds of
other creative entrepreneurs just like
you well then do not miss the chance to
get around creators and business
influencers at growth video live 2022
conference you can actually lock in your
limited discounted tickets at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post or in the
description now if you want to learn the
best new strategies for getting views on
youtube and the most proven and
profitable ways to grow online then do
not miss this life-changing event you
can join us in person in las vegas or
virtually from around the world secure
your ticket at grossvideolive.com and
take the fast track to dominating the
next decade not just with youtube but
with video go to growthvideolive.com or
click the link in this poster in the
description to secure your limited time